yo i'm curious was drake uh ever on set
during the filming of top boy
nah i've never seen him on set but
what's up with that he sucks
he's busy bro yeah yeah yeah he he um
the last time i see drake he come to the
read through you know you do the read
yeah you done the film
did you do a reefer no they didn't
invite it wasn't invited
he doesn't know how to read it what is
that like yeah i don't really do reefers
evil yeah
but but you're invited yeah yeah you got
it you got to go
yeah
but um
he came to the reefer mm-hmm he came to
the reefer
i'm shocked he hasn't done it
he doesn't work i'm shocked he hasn't
been like a small character on the show
or something like that just for fun
because he can act yeah yeah i think
there was some talk of it one time but i
don't know do you do you feel like it
might take a while
yeah like when ed sheeran was in game of
thrones and we were like that's when you
knew it started to suck i love [ __ ]
ed sheeran yeah uh and he could buddy
the role if you want to drake or
whatever but it's still i feel like
you're out of the world
even even like
even if [ __ ] dicaprio is one of my
favorite actors even if he was in top
boy it wouldn't he could take away from
us outsiders almost look at it like a
[ __ ] documentary
you
at least in the states we're like i know
this isn't real but it's cool it is a
lot of people compare it to the wire i
don't know if you saw the wire oh yeah
yeah okay yeah so like for me
i'm watching i'm like oh my god this is
the wire yeah in that here's this like
niche part of this country that has this
incredibly authentic pure grimy
experience and i didn't even know it
existed and i think that's what a lot of
us when we saw top boy for the first
time we're like wait what the [ __ ] is
going on like this is good this is crazy
so putting anybody in that that's
already famous to us takes you out the
world yeah yep 100 so
how is it with like method man in the
world or is memphis man no no that that
[ __ ] it up
oh [ __ ] bro when i found out idris elba
had an accent i was tight
wow i was like what is this [ __ ]
corny [ __ ] well we didn't know it just
like that i never i thought he was
america he because he was in america
forever he
he grew up
um two roads away from me oh wow i
didn't know yeah a state agent told me
when we [ __ ] sold the house that he
sold injuries out to you i was like oh
[ __ ] wow but i just thought idris was
yeah america american actor in in the
wire or whatever yeah yeah but you're
saying oh so when you say i still like
rapping in the shows you might forget i
still like methamphetamine on the wire
but it did take me out a bit what was
interesting about your show though when
it was channel on channel four
yeah
it was it was really a lot like the wire
and i think it's done a good job of
becoming its own show yeah
you arguing with the writers probably
helped that yeah yeah yeah and i think
maybe people's a little bit nervous of
it going to netflix thinking you're
going to try and appeal to a wider
audience and [ __ ] up the show but wider
audience you know i said it's good
exactly but now it's good that is remain
some kind of yeah fantasy and whatnot
yeah okay listen
we're going to a rave
yes i bet you don't i would
i would
if you took me i would go
all right i'm not going to knock on the
door are you
i'm practicing i'm practicing exactly
yeah that's how you do it right
let me just try it one time
i'm just nervous i'm gonna get there i'm
not gonna know how to do it is there can
we just practice well do you know how to
jump
yeah i do okay off the stairs if you
know how to jump and you know how to
spot a one you have to ask a woman if
she would like to dag her
yes in 2022 yeah yeah
now
may i
may i dagger you yes i have this dog
yeah
[Laughter]
okay so we hit this rave tonight
okay we will get it on get our dagger on
mm-hmm uh not all of us al
but there might be a white girl i mean i
think white girls are adopted you know
jamaica
right adele i'm sure adele they're the
ones that they're the real ones around
them yeah white girls even in jamaica
the galdum
say this again tonight because this is
hot off i just lost interest in this
thing completely akash hates white
weapons because he loves them
yeah you see them in jamaica in the real
places whoa dancing in the middle
is it like a study abroad things like
that
really and japanese are women as well
what are they but
what they
and it's like it's crazy is that what
you told yourself
[Music]
you know they go there and pay for
jamaican men to [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
them yeah that's who he is
is that is that true hell yeah
when japanese women do that and white
women
really
no how do you how do you dagger a
japanese it's like
[Laughter]
because the great thing about uh
jamaican woman at a dagger rave
is that they have some cushion they're
like a chesterfield right so it's like
you can jump on them and there's going
to be a thing but if you jump on the
japanese one she actually dives herself
does it herself what do you mean it's a
bit of a kamikaze oh my god oh my
goodness oh my goodness rachel
[Laughter]
isn't some ass required is it like
aren't these like uh these tricks you
know isn't it there's caked up asians
now wait what yeah that's the thing
they've they've come out with like a new
update i think
but there's like i see that no it's a
thing
you haven't seen this japanese girls
will ask it's a new thing hold on show
me no they call them rice cakes i'm
being serious no i'm being serious
that's what happens